a british trawler seized by french
maritime police who say the crew was
fishing for scallops without a permit
that's denied by its owners it may sound
like a small incident but it's
symptomatic of something much bigger a
potential escalation in a post-brexit
fishing rights dispute is causing much
more than a ripple in uk french
relations
it cites for example jersey the british
crown dependency only accepting a third
of the fishing permit applications from
france absolutely
it's time that we are respected it's
totally insufficient and totally
unacceptable so now we must talk the
language of force and unfortunately i
fear that is the only thing this british
government understands
the threats go beyond banning british
trawlers from offloading their catches
at french ports because this only
amounts to a small proportion of exports
without a settlement of the dispute
before next tuesday there'll be rigorous
french customs checks on incoming cargo
and they won't be restricted to seafood
but britain isn't offering any
concessions the measures being
threatened do not appear to be
compatible with the trading cooperation
agreement or wider international law
and if carried through will be met with
an appropriate and calibrated response
this isn't the first time the fishing
rights issue has flared up in may french
trawlers blockaded the main port in
jersey
the british and french deployed a naval
presence during the protests
this time france seems unwilling to back
down on demands
it is not war it's a fight the french
fishermen have some rights an agreement
has been signed we must have
disagreement implemented we have fishing
rights we must defend them and we will
defend them
france is also working on a second round
of sanctions if they're needed and that
could mean a reduction of electricity
supplies to the uk
jersey is 95 dependent on french power
andrew simmons al jazeera